I wanted to talk about atrial fib and
give you some tips that you can try now
just so you know I'm not telling you to
get off your medication
okay that's between you and your doctor
that's my disclaimer but the point is I
want to give you other solutions that
you can try to help your situation okay
number one atrial fib is an electrical
problem of the heart now the question is
why what controls that what controls
electricity of the heart is electrolytes
what are electrolytes those are minerals
that have electrical properties
primarily the real issue with atrial fib
is is magnesium okay so magnesium is a
electrically charged mineral in heart
that allows it to stay in rhythm and if
you have atrial fib the problem is it
increases your risk for stroke by five
to seven times okay but let's just talk
about magnesium for a second now let's
say you had a blood test right and it
comes out normal and you're saying well
I'm fine because I'm I have enough
minerals and things like that first of
all they never check magnesium they
rarely check potassium those are two
main electrolytes because most of the
magnesium even if they did check the the
mineral minerals most of that museum is
in the bone it's inside the cell it's
not in the extracellular fluid like the
blood so that's why it's hard to detect
so magnesium is also present in
vegetables okay so an average person
consumes about 270 milligrams of
magnesium they need double that like 480
that's what they need okay and probably
if they're deficient they need a lot
more so it comes down to a couple
different root causes one is they're not
having enough vegetable in the diet okay
and also potassium you need about 7 to
10 cups of vegetables just to get your
potassium okay but you if you eat
vegetables you'll get both of these
minerals okay
so it's a dietary deficiency issue it
could also be coming because your
digestive system is not right either you
have maybe some Crohn's problem maybe
your gastric bypass maybe your stomach
is not asked
enough do you know you need a really
acid stomach to absorb magnesium yeah in
fact the symptoms of low stomach acid is
heartburn indigestion so if you have
heartburn indigestion that means you
don't have enough acid if you want more
information on that check out my video
I'll actually put a link below but
that's interesting so if you have a
stomach problem that could be why you
have atrial fib because you're not
holding the magnesium in from the diet
okay another cause could be too much
calcium if you're taking calcium what
that will do that will shut down the
absorption of magnesium because they
both work together so if you have this
condition I don't recommend taking any
calcium okay even even like certain
medications for high blood pressure they
give you a calcium channel blocker I
wonder why right the other thing is you
could also have a low vitamin D level
low vitamin D will prevent the
absorption of not just calcium but
magnesium as well so that could be your
real reason why you have the problem
okay so there's a great book it's called
beat your afib by Stephen Ryan PhD I'll
give you a link below I think it's a
great great book if you have this just
to get more information it's backed up
by a lot of credible scientific studies
that you can check it out and use that
to get more knowledge about this issue
but if you're going to get a magnesium
get something called angstrom magnesium
this is a type of magnesium that's a
million times smaller than regular
magnesium supplements out there and so
it goes in like a rocket ship I don't
necessarily recommend taking a potassium
supplement because they only come in 90
99 milligrams and you need forty seven
hundred milligrams you'd have to take
the whole bottle which I don't recommend
so the best thing to do is increase your
salads start having huge salads more
vegetables through the day you have to
bite the bowl and start increasing your
vegetables and you'll see that the
cardiovascular system will start to come
around if you have atrial fib and you
want to replenish these minerals it
doesn't happen overnight okay because by
the time you have atrial fib you really
depleted a lot of yours
in your heart so it takes a while to get
that back it could take easily two three
four plus a month to get that back
alright but this will speed it up and
start eating better and then write your
comments below I'll see you the next
video